aux etats unis face à la chine la
stratégie de joe biden est la même que
celle de donald trump le département
d'état a validé la vente de 750 millions
de dollars à destination de taïwan rival
de pékin on retrouve tout de suite notre
correspondant à washington thomas bonnin
à thomas bonsoir cette manoeuvre a
finalement attiré les foudres de pékin
il s'agit de la première vente d'armes
de la présidence de joe biden à
destination de taïwan 750 millions de
dollars d'armes vendues parmi lesquels
40 systèmes d'artillerie de canons et où
1700 kit permettant de créer des
munitions guidées par gps voici comment
le département d'état américain justifie
ce contrat passé avec taiwan et cette
proposition de vente sert les intérêts
nationaux économiques et sécuritaires
américains en soutenant les efforts
constants du destinataire pour
moderniser ses forces armées et pour
maintenir une capacité défensive
crédible la vente proposée va aider à
améliorer la sécurité du destinataire et
aider à maintenir la stabilité politique
l'équilibré militaire l'économie et les
progrès dans la région le congrès
américain a désormais 30 jours pour
opposer son veto à ce contrat mais cela
est très peu probable parce qu'en
réalité les démocrates et les
républicains sont plutôt aligné sur la
stratégie à adopter vis-à-vis de taiwan
et donc vis-à-vis de la chine il faut
dire qu'en fait joe biden suit la même
politique qui avait déjà été celle de
donald trump
avant lui parce que pendant les quatre
ans de son mandat donald trump a réalisé
18 milliards de dollars de ventes
d'armes à destination de taïwan alors
évidemment ces ventes d'armes
elle agace pékin la chine qui considère
l'île de taïwan comme une partie de son
territoire et qui a vivement réagi à
cette annonce
écoutez les états unis portent atteinte
à la souveraineté aux intérêts
sécuritaires de la chine en vendant des
armes à la région de taïwan
cela va à l'encontre du droit
international et viole le principe d'une
seule chine
la chine demande instamment aux états
unis de révoquer immédiatement les
ventes d'armes concernés afin de ne pas
porter davantage
atteinte aux relations sino américaines
la chine prendra de fer mesures de
représailles appropriées nécessaires en
fonction de l'évolution de la situation
une passe d'armes si vous me permettez
l'expression qui s'inscrit dans un
contexte de tensions grandissantes entre
pékin et washington il ya plusieurs
sujets qui cristallise les tensions il
ya donc ces ventes d'armes qui participe
au renforcement militaire de taiwan mais
il ya aussi les manoeuvres de navires
américains dans le sud de la mer de
chine ou encore les enquêtes sur
l'origine du commis de 19 en passant
évidemment par le sort des ouigours
d'ailleurs joe biden ne s'en cache pas
la chine est pour lui la menace
principale des états unis et cette vente
d'armes elle s'inscrit dans la stratégie
américaine dans la région d'ailleurs le
secrétaire d'état américain à la défense
était la semaine dernière à singapour il
a prononcé cette phrase on ne veut pas
de conflit avec la chine mais on ne
reculera pas si nos intérêts sont
menacés voilà qui donne le ton sur ses
relations particulièrement délicate
entre pékin et washington
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington